Our Scripture reading this morning is Ephesians chapter 2.
Ephesians chapter 2 will be reading verses 11 to 22.
Therefore, remember that at one time, eugenitiles in the flesh called the
uncircumcision by what is called the circumcision, which is made in the
flesh by hands. Remember that you were at the time separated from Christ,
alienated from the commonwealth of Israel, and strangers to the covenants of
promise, having no hope and without God in the world. But now in Christ Jesus,
you who are once far off have been brought near by the blood of Christ.
For he himself is our peace, who has made us both one and has broken down in
his flesh the dividing wall of hostility by abolishing the law of
commandments expressed in ordinances, that he might create in himself one you
man in place of the two, so making peace, and might reconcile us both to God in one
body through the cross, thereby killing the hostility. And he came and preached
peace to you who were far off and peace to those who were near, for through
him we both have access in one spirit to the Father. So then you are no
longer strangers and aliens, but you are fellow citizens with the saints and
members of the household of God, built on the foundation of the apostles and
prophets Christ Jesus himself being the cornerstone in whom the whole
structure being joined together grows into a holy temple in the Lord. In him
you also are being built together into a dwelling place for God by the
spirit. This is the word of the Lord.
Speak up.
If you would pray with me before we get into it.
Father, we thank you so much. Thank you for these words that we read from
Paul from you Lord. I pray that as we seek your word this morning that
your voice would be heard. Lord, that distractions would fall away and
that your spirit would move in our hearts, would stir truth where there may
be falsehood, would bring life where there may be cold stones of our
hearts of stone and that you would speak to us Lord. You would give us ears
to hear eyes to see what you have and that we would leave here changed
because of your goodness. Pray all this in the strong name of Jesus. Amen.
So
I love metaphors. I tend to overdo it actually. I think my wife would
even say that when I'm telling a story, she's probably concerned right
now that I'm going to tell a story. I'm not because I'm not a great
storyteller, but I love metaphors because they help people like me who
are not great storytellers. But I tend to overdo it. It's almost
like I'm beating a dead horse whenever I do it in case you didn't
see what I did there. But it would appear that Paul feels the
same way. So you see throughout his letters to the churches across the
New Testament, he loves metaphors. Then a little bit of digging in
preparation for this. And there's a lot of smart people have a lot to
say about that. But generally metaphors allow us to communicate
really profound truths in a really succinct way. So in this
letter, we've been looking at to the Ephesians, which as Brandon
spoke of when introduced it, this was likely a letter that got
circulated across a lot of churches. So it was a broad audience
that was going to be receiving this, including us today. Many
years later, I don't think Paul had us specifically in mind. But
because of that, we have this introduction in chapter two, where
we've been hearing about being brought from death to life. Brandon
preached last week, Richard a few weeks ago on the weight of
that. And then we're going to move into in chapter three, the
part where we get a little more of the mystery of this gospel
explained where the Jew and the Gentile are merged together
into the family. And then in between this kind of tucked in,
we've got this cascade of metaphors in verses 19 through
22 that we'll be looking at today. So it's like Paul's giving us
this big, huge story of what God's done for us. And then we're
going to move into in the later half of Ephesians, we're going
to look at action steps. We're going to get instructions on
marriage, parenting, we're going to hear about the armor of
God, which is personal favorite of mine from childhood all the
way to today. But then right here, we have these metaphors
meant to communicate something important because Paul never does
anything without it being very intentional here. And so we're going
to look at each of these, but just to list them off, I'm going
to read the passage again, just 19 through 22, just to really
nail down these three things that were told that we are. So
let's listen closely. So then you are no longer strangers and
aliens, but you are fellow citizens with the saints and
members of the household of God built on the foundation of the
apostles and prophets Christ Jesus himself being the cornerstone
in whom the whole structure being joined together grows into a
holy temple in the Lord in him. You also are being built
together into a dwelling place for God by the spirit. So we've
got these three things right. And I'm going to just list them
we've got we're told we're citizens told we're members of
the household of God. And then last we're told that we are a
temple or a dwelling place for the Lord. So we're going to look
at each of these in turn. I just want to say from the
outset, this passage is short, but it is dense. And there is a
lot of that can be said that will not be said here. And so
if something occurs to you or you know something or you see
something, please hold on to it, come talk to me
afterwards or save it for your small group. Because I will be
saying only a sliver of what could be said about this passage
and what we're being told here. But first, we are told we're
citizens. So what does that mean? I think that that's kind of
a word that we can in our current day and age, there's a
lot of talk about citizenship and you know, what might come
to mind for us, there's, you always have to fill out a
form, anybody that's filled out a job application or any kind of
government paperwork recently, you always have to check US
citizen or non citizen. When I was looking at it, I figured I'd
keep it simple and I have a definition according to I think
it's now the artificial intelligence not Google
dictionary. But it says I'm going to trust it a legal
status and relation between an individual and a state or
entity that entails specific legal rights and duties. So for
these people at this time, that this was being written, when
they think of citizenship, they were under the Roman rule. So
Roman citizenship entailed certain legal protections,
political protections, some safety in terms of travel,
property ownership, and it was even often used as a means of
assimilation. So whenever the Roman Empire took over another
nation, usually through war or just a grand show of force, a
lot of the time they would make certain people's citizens to
assimilate. So it was used as a way of bringing people in and
under the rule and authority of the Roman Empire. For us
today, we're, for the most part, I think American
citizens here, some may have citizenship in other
nations as well. But I think that what that kind of entails
is sometimes it's the air we breathe, we don't really think
about it when you check that box. But there's a lot of things
that we take for granted with our citizenship. Anyone who has
ever traveled abroad has felt the maybe the fear that comes
with going somewhere outside your comfort zone where you're
in the minority, you're maybe the only English speaker or the
only American in the room. But when you come into the airport,
especially when you're coming back, and you have the strength
of a US passport gets you in the line to get you home. There's
something about that that is very comforting, but it was very
costly to have that everything that went into your
citizenship. Some of us just got it because we were born
here, right? But it's not so simple as that because
citizenship, both in Roman times and in present day is bound to
an authority. You can't be a citizen alone. If you're a
citizen of one nation, it's just a guy or a girl somewhere.
So making sure that, which brings me to a point that I
should have had earlier, which is that when Paul's
writing this, and this here is pretty obvious, but I don't
think that we should skip over saying when he says you
here. It's more of a y'all. It's more of a you guys, if you're
from somewhere else, but down here, y'all and you can't be a
citizen alone, a nation of one. So that's kind of what it is.
But then looking at how we get it, so we know that the Jews
that he's speaking to, much like us who are Americans,
were born into this type of citizenship that they hold, right?
Which we know is something that they maybe have a certain chip
on their shoulder, according to the writings that we see in
other letters that Paul writes. But then the Gentiles maybe
maybe they were Roman citizens, maybe they weren't. But
recognizing that what he's saying here is pretty disruptive,
because he's saying that you are citizens. Some of them there,
like I said, felt secure inside the circle, so to speak. And
then some did not. And here he's just wiping that away, as we
see in the verse right before, through Christ, we both now have
access by the Spirit to the Father. The next metaphor he
gives us is that we are members of God's household. So in
each of these, there's a vertical component that being our
standing or relationship with God, and also our horizontal. So
our relationship with one another fellow believers. And in
this case, members of the household. There's a quote I
really love that I've heard from from J.I. Packer. I think
it's in knowing God where he says, a Christian is someone
who identifies themselves first and foremost, as a child of
God, who views God as their father. I think that's really
intimate and very intense. And I know not everyone has a great
maybe relationship, maybe you don't even know your father. But
I think that that's really helpful in understanding the
closeness that we're talking about. So in each of these
analogies, in these metaphors, we're going to climb in
intensity and intimacy, both with God and with each other.
And so recognizing that in a household of God, which in other
places, we're told that we are adopted as sons earlier in
Ephesians in chapter one, that he predestined us for adoption
as sons in Romans chapter eight, one of the most pivotal
moments in Paul's writings. He talks about how we've
received a spirit of sonship. And so what that means for
us is that we're not just citizens, we're not just
members of a state or a kingdom. We're called into a
family, which is definitely more intimate and definitely
more disruptive to our lives than just being a citizen,
like looking at the horizontal relationships that we're
talking about here in a few weeks or next week, right?
Thanksgiving for the American citizens. Sorry. But also
Christmas for everyone coming soon is that we're all going to
feel a certain proximity to some people. And it's not going to
be all Americans that are at our table, right? There's
certain people that you're going to be sitting down with
having conversations with, having to eat food that they
prepared that you may or may not be excited about. I
personally am super thrilled. My mother lost here. So I'm
super thrilled about the food that I'm going to be
eating, but I know that that may not be the case. There
may be some tensions, some more superficial, like maybe you
pull for different football teams. Some may be a little
more grating, like political feelings and preferences,
especially in our current time. Some may go even deeper than
that to deep wounds that have broken. There may be
marriages that have been fractured. There may be
strange relationships within the family. But that's not, you
don't feel that with everybody, not all the fellow citizens, but
those in your household, you do. And so what we see is that
for better or worse, we're family. It's for better, by
the way. But that comes with a certain closeness. And I
think that a lot of the time we, we kind of move through
that pretty quickly. But in ancient times, this is
actually really weird. I think, Brandon, you spoke about
this, maybe last week, it could have been someone else. I've
listened to a lot of sermons recently on Ephesians. But
they talked about how the early church was accused of
incest relationships, because they all called each other
brother and sister, even husbands and wives would
refer to each other as brother and sister, which, you
know, is like, whoa, what kind of strangeness is
going on over here? But I think that, you know, growing up,
we called our preacher at our church, brother. Nobody else
was, but, but he was brother. He was either brother or
Dr. Bradley. And, and I just remember that being kind of
an interesting title. But sometimes it would just be
something that we moved through really quickly, without
maybe recognizing that there was meant to be a
closeness. I never thought of him as the same way I thought
about my brothers that I got into arguments with over who
got to sit where at the table, or who got the last bite of
the Thanksgiving food. But there is, we're called to that.
That's what we're told is there. So we're citizens, and
then moving a little closer to one another, Thanksgiving
dinner or, or other family dinners. And those friction
points, so we're family members of the household, children of
God. And then last, the dwelling place, the temple of the
Lord being built into a temple with Christ himself as our
cornerstone. So this one's actually a little bit harder
for us to, to quickly move through. Like I said, there's
a lot that can be said about each of these. I'm trying
really hard to move quickly through them just to make sure
that we at least touch them all. But when we think about
being built into a temple, there's obviously the, the
physical, we have structures such as even this pavilion that
we're in that required planning and, and building that
kind of makes sense. But we're, we're people. For, for the
audience here, and for Paul as a Jew, what they're talking
about here is actually the presence of God. Now, each of
us has been taught, I imagine, or heard, you know, we hold
that God is, is present in all places at all times. It's
the nature of God, something about him that is different
from us. But in, in the Old Testament, when he comes and
comes to Moses and then frees the Israelites, and when they're
wandering in the desert, he gives them the instructions. And
I hope I'm not messing with the history here. I apologize.
I thought I would remember more. But he gives him the
instructions for the tabernacle, which is a mobile
structure that they are given very specific instructions on
how to build it out. There's different, everything to the
how the furniture is arranged to the different rooms and how
it's constructed is laid out for them. And this is, this is
given to them in order that there would be an intimate
meeting place between their representative, who was the
high priest, which would have been a member of the tribe
of Levi. Their intermediary would meet God in this
place where his presence was specifically felt and known. So
he was making himself available to the people in this place. So
the tabernacle is, is an example of really a return to what
they, what we had in Eden, right? And Genesis, right at
the beginning, we're told that the Lord walked with Adam in
the garden. And, and so we're trying to recover that. And
the first step that he gives us is the tabernacle. So this is
his dwelling place. This is where he meets us. So when we're
told we're being built into a temple, that's kind of our
first indicator is this is not just a metaphor for a cool
like, yeah, you guys are gonna, somebody's gonna be this
beam and somebody's gonna be the roof. Somebody's gonna be
this, that and the other. We're told that we're being
built into a dwelling place for God. Now, we're gonna, we're
gonna get into maybe the little bit more of that in just a
second. But moving from that, this is an important point that
we get having our New Testament in fullness is in John. So
when we talk about the dwelling place of the Lord in John
chapter one, I'm sure many of us are familiar with, with
his writing of the word became flesh. The word was with God,
the word was God. But in verse 14 of the first chapter, John
were told, and the word being Jesus became flesh and dwelt
among us. And we have seen his glory, glory as of the only
son from the Father full of grace and truth. So this, this
word here, where it talks about the word became flesh and
dwelt among us. It's actually, according to some smarter people
than me who are familiar with Biblical languages, we're told
that he tabernacled among us. So this is another call back to
this intimate presence of God coming and being present with
us available to us. So Jesus is not only our mediator, our
high priest, but he's also the presence of God among us.
So that means when we're being told we're being built into
this foundation, we have crisis our cornerstone. Everything is
going to be oriented around the cornerstone. I don't know much
about buildings, but I know you have to have a point of
orientation. Otherwise, it's going to be not right angles,
right? Not standing, it's going to lean. It won't hold.
So we have a tabernacle, Jesus, and then it's almost like this
progression which is would have been unheard of to these
people and and really is even mind boggling at this point. But
we're told that we are going to be this dwelling place. Not
not me individually necessarily, but us as the church. So this
is where the lines I feel like between the vertical and the
horizontal almost are hard to distinguish because we're being
told that we're being laid alongside one another in such a
way that we are closer than family, right? When stones are
placed on top of one another, they're meant not to move,
they're mortar together. They are part of something where they
both stand alone. If I just set a stone here, you would say,
that's a rock. That's great. That's not a structure, right?
It takes a builder. It takes time, design, planning. And first
Peter, Peter actually gives us a very similar metaphor when he
says in this first Peter two five says you yourselves like living
stones are being built up as a spiritual house to be a holy
priesthood to offer spiritual sacrifices acceptable to God through
Jesus Christ. And he says for it stands in scripture behold, I
am laying in Zion, a stone, a cornerstone, chosen and precious
and whoever believes in him will not be put to shame. So we are
being built into a living temple. It's pretty, pretty wild. I
think I think that this is something that I tend to move
pretty fast through this part of Ephesians because I want to
get to the really good coffee cup verses, right? And then the
ones that you get, like I said, you get to the armor of God and
that just gets you really fired up about being equipped and
ready to take on whatever the devil is going to bring, right?
We're going to extinguish the arrows. But I think that this
is important that we sit here with this for a minute. And
each of these metaphors, citizens, members of the
household of God, children of God, and then last being a
temple, a dwelling place for the Lord, each of them have
insight for us on our identity. And I think that's what Paul
is trying to do here actually is we've been told over the last
few weeks and looking at the first couple chapters of
Ephesians, he goes through his greetings, his prayers. He then
moves into a really powerful, like I said, the last few weeks
we've got to look at a really powerful summary of the gospel
that God has brought us from death to life and this by grace.
And so we have this amazing peace offered to us by grace.
And we've talked about how that's been achieved through the
blood of Christ, not by any works that we have done, but
that we are his workmanship. And then here, before we get
into maybe the action steps, so to speak, we're told about our
identity. So I'm going to use a metaphor that I'm really not
qualified to use here. So I think that the next few
chapters in Ephesians are going to be really practical. We have
a lot of really practical things that are coming. And my
metaphor is not as good as Paul's, but mostly because I don't
know much about computers. But I know there's a difference
between software and hardware, right? So I recently got an
update on my computer. It's an Apple computer. And so the
software is designed for that hardware. Now when we get to
the passages of scripture where we're told how to love our
spouse as Christ loved the church and when we're told how to
not exasperate our children and we're told how to love them,
that's kind of like software, right? Instructions on how to
do things. But if we don't have the right hardware, if we
don't know the system that we're operating on, the
actual equipment, if we haven't been given a new heart, if we
haven't moved from death to life, then we have no way of
performing these duties. People hear these things and they
think, oh, it's just so simple as this. But then you try to do
any good task without being a sinner is really hard, right?
And so understanding that Paul is about to give us this
charge. And he's told us all this wonderful things. I think he
really wants us to recognize who we are, which is actually one of
the titles I considered for the sermon was Who in the World Are
We?
There's a lot of people competing to answer that
question. Some overtly, very obviously, your boss at work,
maybe, or your parents, or your children, or your friends,
they may tell you who you are explicitly. There's a lot more
implicit stories out there about who you are. You know, I think
a lot of political advertisements and even ads I saw on TV
yesterday, they make a lot of assumptions, or maybe you're
trying to kind of, what is it, a little nudge one way or the
other about who you are? Who you are as a man, as a woman, as an
American?
We're told that we are meant to be happy, that we are to have
things come to us. We're told, life's supposed to be easy.
Scripture would tell us otherwise. When we're told that
we are going to be the dwelling place of God, which would be to
be as Christ was, we're told that we're going to suffer. I think
that our identity, which feels very self-achieved when you
listen to the voices of the world, and even the
conversations that you may have yourself. Identity is something
that you build. But here we're told we're given an identity. So,
which one is it? There's a couple of thoughts on wisdom that
I found really helpful when I was trying to piece together
some of this. According to, I didn't get the name, according to
one Hebrew scholar, when we see the word wisdom in Scripture,
the easiest way to sum up what wisdom was to these people who
were writing a lot of these scriptures was competence
regarding the challenges of life. And there's another quote
that I found in the Bible by John Calvin. And I have not read
the institutes, but apparently it starts with a really strong
line. This is true in sound wisdom consists of two parts, the
knowledge of God and of ourselves. I'm a nurse. That's my
profession. So everything is very practical in terms of when I
approach things. What's going to be good for me here? What's
going to be good for the people around me? And so I really
wanted to come with something practical, maybe three great
steps that you could take. I think that there's probably many
great steps that you could take. But I think that what Paul is
doing in this passage is almost an assurance, an imparting of
of truth and wisdom that allows for us to have competence for the
challenges of life. Because if if we're not citizens, then we
have no rights. If we're not children, then we don't have
access to this God, this King. But if we're being built into a
dwelling place, and we are citizens, we are children,
then we do have access. And I think that I think that position
is very important. You hear some talk about there's, there's
the position of the Christian, and then there's the practice of
the Christian. And those of us who grew up in this place,
position and practice go hand in hand. We live in a meritocracy
right? If you if you work hard, and you're smart, pay
your dues, generally you will get to where you need to be. But
that's not what we're told. We that whole thing gets flipped on
its head here. We're told that we are positioned as children.
We've been granted citizenship, not because of we filled out the
right paperwork, passed the right test, got born in the
right place. Simply by grace. Told that we're children, not
again, not by birth, we're adopted, chosen. And then last
that we're being built. stones don't construct themselves. So
I think recognizing that our position, it's, it's really
secure.
think that we tend to, especially those of us who've been in
church a long time. Sometimes we can hear these metaphors and
they just, I don't know, they don't carry the weight, right?
They don't feel as as heavy as they maybe once did. So the last
thing that I want to get into is, is maybe what this means.
We've been told that we're citizens, we've been told that
we're children, dwelling place of God. Maybe that moves you.
Maybe it feels
very simple.
But I want to, I want to point out that
there's a fulfillment. There's a big story being told and Paul is
is interacting with that story.
In Genesis chapter 12, verses one through three, this is the Lord
coming to man we would later call Abraham, Father Abraham, those
who grew up in church. I'm going to read this and I want to
recognize that this is, it's time about us in this passage
strangely enough. Now the Lord said to Abraham, go from your
country and your kindred and your father's house to the land that
I will show you. And I will make of you a great nation and I
will bless you and make your name great so that you will be a
blessing. I will bless those who bless you and him who
dishonors you. I will curse and in you all the families of the
earth shall be blessed. In you all the families of the earth
shall be blessed. So Paul's kind of bringing us to this point.
We are the ones who are being blessed because from the line
of Abraham we can track came the Christ. And so as we're called
to be a living temple, the dwelling place of the Lord,
I think that it's really easy for that to be something over
there, something or maybe up in the air somewhere. But what
that means for us now is that we have access and that means
that we have hope. And I think something that we talked about
in our small group last week, grace and peace, are offered to
us. There's a whole lot we can say about that from this
passage. It's not being said. So feel free to unpack that.
But I think that I always kind of come back to a quote whenever
I'm trying to wrestle with these things. There's a C.S. Lewis quote
in The Weight of Glory where he says, our God does not, it
would seem, does not find our desires too strong but too
weak. And so I'm going to read this passage about a promise
that we have. And I guess my call is really just to embrace
our given identity. Stop trying to prove your other identities
that may fade, that may be based on you or based on your
position that's temporary but one that's permanent.
This is a passage in Revelation that we're told is going to be,
this is John writing what he sees in heaven. This is Revelation
21. This is verses, I will go to and three and four, sorry.
And I saw the holy city, New Jerusalem, coming down out of
heaven from God, prepared as a bride adorn for her husband.
And I heard a loud voice from the throne saying, behold, the
dwelling place of God is with man. He will dwell with them
and they will be his people. And God himself will be with
them as their God. He will wipe away every tear from their
eyes and death shall be no more. Neither shall there be
mourning nor crying nor pain anymore for the former things
have passed away. So
we see that the dwelling place of the Lord is with his people.
By grace we are those people. We are his children. We have
access to him and this is by grace. And so
I've heard a lot of great sermons end with like this call to
action or a call for repentance. And I think all of those
things are warranted. But I would really just want you to
hear that as a child of God, you have access to the Father.
The best earthly fathers are but a shadow of what we have
in our Heavenly Father. And if you can imagine and receive the
truth that your position as a child as a part of this
household, as a part of this structure and this dwelling
place is secure. Because what we're going to be getting
into the next few weeks is going to maybe sound impossible or
aspirational at times idealistic. But your position is secure.
If you are a child of God, then he is true to see you through.
And these steps that we're going to take and the
journey that we're on together will be in him. And it won't be
one that has to be wondered about. So, yeah, hear that please.
And I'm going to pray for us.
Father, thank you so much for the goodness of your grace.
For the fullness that we have, the peace that is available to us.
Lord, I thank you for this promise, this new identity that we receive.
Not one that can be built up by human hands or taken away by human powers, but
has been formed by you in your planning, in your blood,
and it is upheld by your spirit. So, Lord, I pray that as we go from this place that your
spirit would maintain us, uphold us, and that we would be transformed by the goodness of
your grace and its truth moving further into our hearts.
Bless us as we go from here and bless this worship as we continue.
In Jesus' name, amen.